welcome to this video playing game BOGO
SS what Talib a girl yes it's a grand
master let's see what he's doing yeah i
played him a tournament in my your car
on my yoga in inmate and i posted some
games of that and this guy does grandma
see also played this tournament he
managed something not so easy he lost
the first two rounds against players
much weaker than him ok so i just made a
complete centralization I mean he hasn't
even developed dry completely what about
this d6 pawn is this good for wide night
be three community XD six very simple
and still I'm not quite sure what he's
doing against it stuff like a five maybe
or something man I just take these six
bishop fa de back again maybe Bishop c4
and what exactly
you
what a weird game or am I completely
overlooking stuff here I have everything
in play and he's got nothing out yeah
okay might be six some somehow this is
possible or I can take a sixth rack um
yeah here rook takes Knight b6 might be
not that clear but I can take with the
Queen might be 66 now look T 1 yeah I
can take this seven here that's it but
it's both is good this is also good
ja his King side is not exactly exactly
strong yeah I can take here and then
gunite c5 ummm not sure what is best
here I mean I can start as I can play
that first and then consider this is
just good it's not so clear how good it
is but it looks really nice this pin on
the D file I'd lease them get a piece
back probably more yeah 97 that's also
c7 the Queen does not have many squares
but ok I'll take care first so Bishop
takes Knight takes Knight takes 22 and I
win the peace this is this is why you
didn't do that I can take on c8 Queen
takes but Bishop c7 I will win the Queen
not sure if this is so great I check
here
no bishop see 727s really is hanging on
this is this is also quite strong taking
attacking all his weaknesses
yeah looked in on g3 is threatening on
g3 can go look this seven down the
counter counter media on cannot take
here unfortunately
hmm here was this so great what I played
here probably not hmm yeah probably
should have won the Queen yeah okay
hindsight is always twenty-twenty Jim g3
was hanging g-form
takes checks beautiful I already spotted
this game should be over long ago but I
didn't I simply didn't manage so looked
you one for the trade yes check okay
pushed me to h3 which is really where I
want to be I guess
nida form this is what I want to do for
26 winning this pawn without the King
it's not so easy now come on this is
this is right get the knight to f3 and
then make sure that the king is coming
out that's it sets better from a
technical point of view and also of
course before I can take the form that
said that's in fact the idiot jam it
wasn't so great if he takes his bishop
is protecting g5 ok now that now again
is an easy win it's really playing this
a bit bit strange fashion but ok this is
probably losing anyway with the hardest
this much material deficit
96
and now we let the clock run down
yeah okay g7 I can also start with this
move check
black4 fits on time jammed and this game
lasted far longer than it should I
really don't know what did I do wrong
here maybe I should have won the Queen I
mean gee I should have just won the
Queen okay this is I mean there are
alternatives but it's definitely winning
yeah maybe I should take care should
take with the night probably this is
this is Clara to avoid this this whole
thing the problem is that this is always
very easily winning winning this this
piece and I didn't really didn't really
see that Bishop c5 was on and of course
this was the winner of the Queen as I
mentioned but I wasn't sure how easy
this is probably I should still do that
it's its Queen against my nappies and
rook yeah it's puts probably platinum it
this is still very much overwhelming but
I lost time here and allowed some some
more activity than then what was really
was necessary Jim here it doesn't feel
that clear I am I advantageous going
down from it was like plus 3 and now I
just plus 1 yeah for some reason he
allowed whoop t1 and after that it it
really should be a winning endgame for F
for getting back here yeah I thought I
thought this would be a little bit
tougher because he's got this protected
but still I'm going to go into Winnie
img2 and so on it is too much it's too
much material but hmm yeah this is so
this is still something that needs to be
warm I mean especially if you consider
that he might go there that was much
tougher much
I'm actually winning here really wonder
now that's not clear at all it's not
clear my night is really sorry PCM I
should I should try to be quick here to
get the King into the game can you just
go for the a pawn let's go here here
yeah nap the Seaport okay so you cannot
go here because the sea porn will will
start to run something something like
that my pawns are too quickly the
airport is nice but I get a Jeep on and
so on chair maybe it I don't know it
what it would have been much tougher if
you played a plate like that okay thanks
for watching